let's jump into this first story we have
this tweet from the washington free
beacon
a pro-abortion house oversight witness
refuses to say if she agrees with
infanticide
rep norman quote do you support
infanticide killing a child after he is
born witness i do not agree with the
basis of that question but i do believe
that abortion is healthcare i'll play
you the clip but i want to show you this
you scroll down a second witness refuses
to say if she agrees with infanticide we
don't have infanticide happening what i
think is based on your question you have
very low opinion of pregnant people
pregnant people a third pro-abortion
witness refuses to say if she agrees
with infanticide could you answer that
yes or no how you just characterized the
representative statement is extremely
inflammatory let me tell you something
we had this uh progressive on and he
kept saying that late term abortion
doesn't happen later abortion doesn't
happen and i said okay i don't care i'm
asking you why democrats tried to
legalize that recently joe manchin is
the reason that didn't go through and he
says but it doesn't happen okay bro
maybe it doesn't happen because it's
illegal
maybe maybe it's not allowed to happen
is that is that the is that the point
and if democrats legalize it will happen
let me play this clip for you because i
want to talk about how insane things are
getting
i assume you agree with infanticide the
killing of a child a perfectly healthy
child at birth
i don't accept the basis of that
question but i do believe abortion is
health care
i'm talking about do you agree i i know
i get that but do you agree i mean are
you in do you support infanticide
killing the child after he's born
i do not agree with the basis of that
question but i do believe that abortion
is health care
why is it so difficult just be like yeah
we shouldn't kill babies that are born
okay next question are these people
considered
witnesses right now uh they they are
witnesses i'm not sure they're sworn are
they allowed to be treated hostilely of
course
why don't they say i'm going to treat
this person hostile like if they're
refugees
examine them he's trying to
uh they look they've obviously been
highly prepared look when i get a
witness on a stand they're highly
prepared i usually you know i always
have a jury there right so jury's seeing
things there's no jury here this is all
political propaganda and what they want
to do is avoid making any concession
to normal people about the normal idea
that you don't kill babies okay not a
radical notion but they can't say that
they don't want a clip of one of them
out there going you know i think you'd
be wrong if you killed a baby the other
part of it too is they would have to if
they wanted to say that infanticide was
wrong right the next question would be
at what point in birth at what age bingo
does the you know infant have to be
during the gestation process for it to
be infanticide so that's part of the
issue we've had these conversations with
people on this show
with uh uh and and and they just refuse
to answer and there's no answer and i
i've asked we to progressive and i said
okay there's two women
they got pregnant the exact same time
the babies have gestated for the exact
same amount of time eight and a half
months one woman gets a c-section the
baby is pulled from her womb the other
one does not
can you abort the baby in the womb
they say yes they're like well yeah it's
a woman's choice it's a woman's choice
what about the baby who's born no that
would be wrong and i'm like okay wait
what why well that's a big concern well
that's that's exactly what they didn't
want to answer
right in the house today they don't want
to have to say what abortion actually is
which is killing a baby they don't want
to say they just don't want to say it i
have a lot more respect for people who
say you know i'm in favor of abortion
and abortion is murder because at least
that's totally honest
well honestly i don't know if i have
respect for them i just
i mean
you're a terrible terrible human being
but you're at least not lying to me
about that person and you're not lying
to yourself like these people are lying
to themselves
i think that's wrong because they don't
believe anything she knows what
infanticide is she knows what a woman is
but do you know why they refuse to
answer
because they will be attacked by the
left oh yeah because the goalposts move
so rapidly on the left that their their
allegiance is to the cult and not to any
morals
so they're they're probably sitting
there thinking like if i say i oppose
this and then in a week we are in favor
of it i'm going to get canceled so i
better not say anything other than
whatever the approved line is well and
there is no cohesive value system so
there's nothing to base these judgments
on it's what needs to be said look
the left could just as easily
been radically pro-life
if that was to their advantage they
could be saying we are not going to
allow you to murder young babies
future democrat welfare recipients we
are not allowing that
that's horrible that's a that's terrible
your human life i you could but they
don't have kids
well there are reasons why they chose to
go that way but don't don't
i mean the the idea that some sort of
moral uh uh choice of theirs they would
have gone the airway if it was useful to
their agenda i i and has been in some
countries maybe maybe but i think it's
useful to their agenda not in the way
you're saying
it's useful to their agenda because they
don't like people because they want to
reduce the amount of people well that's
true this is the funny thing there's a
meme you are the carbon they are trying
to reduce
but hold on bill gates literally wrote
that i think it was in reuters in 2018
saying
poverty is expanding because poor people
are having kids and we need to give them
birth control to stop this and i'm like
they're quite literally saying less
people because it's causing climate
change so these democrats don't want
people the problem is when they are more
likely to sterilize their kids more
likely to abort their kids
and conservatives are not
the future is conservative it's just a
simple mathematical equation are you
you're right about that and i and i
think if you watch this they are
conceding
that normal people will find their
beliefs repellent right now
even every time even 30 years ago when
you had uh bill clinton and you had
people
thinking well safe legal and rare which
was a brilliant formulation
even even
gently pro-life people could go well you
know at least he's thrown on all a
branch at least he says you know they we
all agree
that this is a disfavored thing i had a
uh a leftist friend go kurt no one is
for abortion well that's we now know
that's no longer changing you show them
the lena dunham quote where she said she
wished she had an abortion well there's
that she doesn't have a child she just
wanted to kill once and there was also
there was a lindy west right who came
out with that book pro and it was like
we are pro-abortion that's what we need
to
start going with now but but these
people when they're doing politics
not in their own personal echo chamber
they are trying desperately not to show
normal people what they really think
because you go out to a normal person
and one who may be a little bit kind of
well you know she's gotten in trouble
it's the first few weeks i can deal with
that but you go yeah we're you know you
can abort this kid pretty much until he
gets his driver's license
and they're just going what what is
wrong with you
no normal human being says eight eight
and a half eight months
four uh three weeks and go ahead and
abort no normal first ever they're like
what are you talking about because
that's way past the point of viability
well it's insane yeah but they're
amazing but the law their logic
forces them to accept it but they can't
say it out loud i think it was vosh and
i think it was on this show
he was asked i think i think was when we
had charlie kirk and vashon when did
when does life begin and vos said some
time after birth yeah i think right
that's interesting noted theologian that
sounds like a
misspeak if he said that because no i
mean you're obviously alive when you're
born no they they genuinely
uh there have been arguments from more
extreme pro-abortion individuals that
memories don't form until three months
after you're born oh it's now memories
so
you don't need to be have memories in
order to be able well i want to clarify
that because these are the same people
who insist we eat bugs so we don't
slaughter cattle and pigs
are pigs and cattle alive well it's not
so why it's not about that it's about
climate change well it's about they're
not saying yeah yeah they're not saying
to eat crickets because they want to
save the animals i mean some people are
they're saying cows fart too much like
aoc put out that thing where it was like
farting cows so they put crickets but of
course the real reason they want us to
eat bugs is because it's degrading
humiliating and we enjoy eating beef and
that we are peasants and we need to
suffer i disagree i disagree i think
it's actually much much simpler than
that crickets are cheap crickets are
cheap and if you can start a cricket
that's cheap i used to buy crickets for
my euromastics lizards damn things
online
once they're mastered
do you know how long it takes to get to
raise beef cattle
it takes a while a couple years i was
talking to the farmer and i said how
like you get all this beef they got
tenderloin and stuff it's amazing i love
it and i said how how how long from the
cow being born to like they're ready to
be chopped up and they're like two years
a cricket is like a week
and so you get a big vet you mass
produce garbage cheap protein crickets
and and here's what happens you're like
not only is it cheap to make but
it's uh it's easy to like pulverize
produce this food
now you need to convince people to buy
it it's cheap to make and there's an
opportunity to invest so people like
bill gates these other people i don't
know if he's doing this but they invest
in cricket production and then they
start dumping money into news programs
being like oh you you gotta eat the
crickets everybody's getting busted
their companies start doing better and
better and better and then they put out
videos of nicole kidman eating bugs and
everybody yeah what would you call it
doc
that's
after tom cruise it's the second
weirdest thing
um look no i i i think
i think we're overlooking
the remember uh
marxism this whole leftist woke thing is
really a psychodrama and it's about
their feels
there is a certain joy in compelling
other people to do degrading things and
it is degrading to eat bugs
steak is the
uh
food of a citizen of a proud male or
female a proud human being
and bugs bugs are what you give to
servants and serves and they get off on
that you know what i love there was like
a post where someone said 80 percent of
the world eats bugs no and then it
showed well it showed people eating bugs
and then someone responded with like the
reason they eat bugs is because they're
poor well yeah like it's like to the
extent that they're not you're not
saying they do it because they're proud
to do it and they're doing this they
have no choice you know to the extent
that they're slurping up millipedes like
uh the you know the dogs and lady and
the [ __ ] i'm sorry uh i mean it tastes
good yeah it's just no we had cricket
yeah it's nobody's first choice the
first choice of any human being is a
delicious uh grilled rib eye tender rib
eye tenderloin
man i would say pasta oh my gosh
yeah carbs glutens every time every time
be gone with you i had a fillet uh a
bowl of bullionaires on some pasta
you said that the left could easily have
just been anti-abortion um
useful to them does it do you think that
this iteration of the left meaning i
don't know what how you would define it
exactly is it like a communist radical
attempt at an overthrow of the current
state of governance i think it you know
i think it is i think it is a bunch of
uh
uh perpetual
wellesley sophomores living out their
daddy psychodrama issues and the guys
who are trying to have sex with them and
i think that that is
really the essence i think it is a uh i
think they are
there's a space in everybody for to be
filled with some sort of spirituality
you know you know you're maybe you're a
christian maybe you're an orthodox jew
maybe you're just kind of spiritual in
general maybe you have some sort of
rational belief
system which doesn't involve a guy but
you fill it with something that's not
crazy but if you don't fill it with
something that's not crazy it gets
filled with something that's crazy
that's why these guys have this
religious mindset complete with heretics
us we're all heretics they'd happily
burn us and and sacraments like abortion
but this is why apostates are so bad and
heavily targeted people who are like
they really don't like people who were
woke and then walk away yeah look you
you were associated with the left
uh
and they hate you
so uh prager uh prager you had that dave
rubin thing why i left the left and then
i told him i was like you got to make a
video called how the left left me yeah
and i was like because my position
stayed basically the same it's like that
elon musk meme that was actually a colin
wright meme showing how the left has
just continually gone insane and the the
infanticide abortion thing is the
perfect example
a year ago they're like it's not
happening you're crazy now they're like
i'm not i'm not answering that question
i refuse like we are inching towards
them to where they get to the point
where they're going to be like well
you call it infanticide but if the child
is is malformed or it has it's
convenient you know what i you know
what's crazy to me there's a meme i see
these leftists post and it shows a like
a slum house covered in graffiti and a
child sleeping on a scuzzy mattress and
it said just because he was born doesn't
mean he was saved and i was like are you
advocating for killing that child like
it's a it's are you saying it shouldn't
be alive
this is the thing they always say right
it's like oh you only care for children
before they're born but if you would
care for them afterwards we wouldn't
have to abort them and it's like
what are you talking about and there's i
have to kill them you don't care you
don't care well you know it it may be a
little rude to our leftist friends but
you know marxists murdered a hundred
million people in the last century
that's inconvenient those are
interesting there's there's
they're just cambodians right i love
this there's a meme from uh existential
comics or accidentals comics that i see
posted all the time and it's like it
says something dumb it's like we're made
to believe that communism is bad because
a famine happened once and i'm like yo
every time 100 million dead right
man these people are absolutely insane
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm we'll see you all there
you